okay the guests today on my right is
David Arnold who's composed for a range
of films and television that include
Independence Day very funky score for
John Singleton's remake of shaft Hot
Fuzz Little Britain to his right is
Antonio Sanchez who composed the music
for Berlin at Birdman even or the
unexpected virtue of ignorance which
remarkably is his first film score and
my far right is Johan Johansson he
composed the lyrical music for the
theory of everything I'm telling you
your first film
Birdman actually let's talk about how
you got involved in it because it's such
a unique approach to including a score
in the film when Alejandro approached me
you know I just love his movies I love
alejandro I don't know any other
directors personally or or anything the
music and film is something I never
pursued because I have a very fulfilling
career as a jazz musician and you know
it was never in my on my radar I love
movies and I love music and I love
Alejandro so when he approached me about
the idea of having just drums I was like
if you want just drops in your movie I'm
your man that's done and and it's
interesting because the way everything
started evolving it was also natural and
organic and very effortless you know of
course when he approached me about it
I was elated and petrified at the same
time because elated man to to have a
chance to work with them in a film with
you know the cast that it has and you
know it was just a an amazing dream to
begin with but also like not too many
points of reference what I could do you
know how I could approach this this
project but I thought if he thinks it's
gonna work it's probably gonna be cool
and my first instinct was to try to
write very organized
you know rhythmic patterns for the
domain characters for different scenes
and I sent him the demos and he was like
you know that's exactly the opposite of
what I want like so what do you want
like man I want something really organic
spare of the moment almost like I wanted
to sound improvised you're a jazz
musician I want you to play jazz only
often so that's easy you know because
that's what I do every day you know on
stage so that's that's how it got
started I mean it was it's been a crazy
ride cultural genocide you guys are
perpetrating you know the douchebags
born every minute that was PT Barnum's
premise when he invented the circus and
nothing much has changed you guys know
that it can crank out any toxic piece of
crap
people all line up and pay to see it but
long after you're gone I'm gonna be on
that stage earning my living baring my
soul wrestling with complex thinking
about the way that a director's
relationship develops with a
cinematographer
with Neda to who they always have them
close at hand that's not necessarily
always the case with a composer music is
usually the one thing that a director
can't do you know they could probably
shoot the film you know they could
probably edit the film a lot of them can
and do I work with directors who have
been the cinematographer as well you
know they're in the cutting room they're
sitting on the shoulder of the editor
you know there's there's not much of the
process of filmmaking that most
directors couldn't do in terms of sort
of key things or could make a hefty step
stab at at least but music is that thing
that terrifies them a lot because it's a
it's a language that is so specific and
so removed from the practical point of
lenses and lights and you know like how
many lights do we need in here what what
what's the aperture what's our stop
what's our focal length you know these
things are sort of physical things and I
know there's a huge amount of creativity
goes into making those things work
beautifully but
music appears to be to a lot of director
summit which is quite terrifying they
can't really put their finger on
specifics like like you could with with
a bit production design you know that we
always find that directors work most
effectively with me when they talk
purely in in emotional terms and some of
them speak to in emotional terms some of
them speak to you very specifically
about instruments and some of them don't
speak to you at all and and it's a great
very extent I like it when they don't
really speak to me I mean obviously you
need to know what you know what the show
needs but if they're at that point where
they say do you know what you know I'd
like to hear what you've got to add to
it and what you're bringing to it and
some directors do and those are the ones
that I tend to work with quite a lot
obviously they have an opinion and
obviously they'll say something but if
they talk to me in emotional terms I
find that far more effective in terms of
how I would respond to it and it's
interesting that you you say that about
the way that you work with I know David
Lynch does the same thing you know he
walks through a scene with the composer
and and they write stuff as he speaks to
them and they become the bedrock of what
of what the school should be but that
impressionistic approach to a film I
think is one of the most important
things that you that you can do because
what you think what music should be
doing in a film is it's too abstractly
represent the film away from the film so
if you hear it somehow you feel what
that film is you know you get an
understanding of the of the kind of heat
and the fender and the ferocity and the
rhythm and the color of it and I found
over the years I've changed the way that
I've that I've worked I used to work
starting from the front of the film
working through to the end scoring out
each scene but if you're scoring a scene
that's that you know that's that's a
very specific kind of mechanical job of
making music fit someone moving from
into a door over there walking stopping
talking over there getting hit by
something and then leaving you know I
mean those moments that you have to
punctuate and get out of the way of a
dialogue there's like there's a
mechanical part of composition which is
dealing with the structure of the music
but ultimately it's the the music is
them it's the most important thing
and now I kind of take a similar
approach you know it's like I'll watch a
film I might watch it once or twice and
then not look at it for two weeks and
walk around with it internally not
necessarily a piano not necessarily a
guitar or whatever it is that we use it
but somehow letting it sink in and then
you know you come up with an in with
with an impression your your your filter
of the film's emotional core through
what you're doing and then then you
start coming up with ideas and then I
you know now I write ideas like in
little two or three-minute sweets and
it's not won't fit the picture it's not
designed to fit the picture but
hopefully if you play it to someone they
say I can hear the film somehow in that
so I've sort of changed a lot but yeah
directors emotional far more effective
than I think that clarinet might be
better on it in my experience you know
the my the directors I work with work
very closely with with editors and in
terms of also in terms of the music and
in terms of how they how they sort of
work the music into into the film and
and and so it's it's in my experience
it's been like almost like a three-way
collaboration between you know composer
director and editor and I record it very
much like a collaboration you know for
me it's like like being in a band you
know your your your your you're working
with with you know our artists of a very
you know we're working at a very high
level and they're not musicians you know
they're not they're not necessarily
musical but they they have like editors
do quite often have a musical background
but it but it's it's it's also very
different you know depending on when
when you join the film for example with
any villain of he brings me on very
early you know before the shop before
they start shooting and he usually
invites me just to the set and and I
hang around and and sort of absorbed the
the atmosphere and and we have talks and
and it's quite abstract I mean he gives
me you know he talks you know in very
emotional terms and in very sort of
nonspecific very very very very abstract
and and and then for exam
Sicario that I'm working on now I got a
like a long three-hour cut with with no
music at all I mean they they cut it
without music and without any time music
do you prefer which one they're both
great they're both you know just
different ways of working and and and i
think i think i think i prefer in many
ways you know being brought brought on
early earlier because you you can really
become much more of a part of the DNA of
the film i think you know and and if
you're if you're there from the from the
beginning and and so that that's that's
a very privileged position to be and i
think to be to be to be there early on
and
you